ONE SHINING MOMENT.
♪
>> AWAY WE GO FROM INDY.
>> READY TO RUN IT BACK FOR MORE
MARCH MADNESS.
>> THE WHOLE DANCE IS RIGHT HERE
IN THE GREAT STATE OF INDIANA.
>> BASKETBALL IS WOVEN IN THE
FABRIC OF THE CITY.
>> LET THE MADNESS BEGIN.
>> WE WAITED TWO YEARS FOR THIS
AND HERE WE GO.
♪ THERE YOU ARE YOU RUN FOR YOUR
LIFE ♪
♪ YOU'RE A SHOOTING STAR AND ALL
THE YEARS ♪
♪ NO ONE KNOWS ♪
>> THEY'RE FIRST EVER NCAA
VICTORY.
>> IT'S MARCH!
EXPECT THE UNEXPECTED!
>> WATCH OUT.
>> BELIEVE THE UNBELIEVABLE!
♪
>> A LITTLE NYLON FROM DEEP.
>> THE UPSETMAKERS ARE
HISTORYMAKERS.
>> ANOTHER FAIRY TALE RIDE.
>> WOW.
>> GOODNESS.
>> REESE.
>> YEAH, OVERTIME.
>> BULLS EYE!
>> FROM THE FIRST FOUR TO THE
FINAL FOUR!
>> THE COUGARS ARE GOING TO THE
FINAL FOUR.
>> IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME COMING.
>> THEY ARE UNBEATEN WITH
HISTORY IN THEIR CROSS HAIRS.
>> MITCHELL.
WANTS ANOTHER THREE AND HE FINDS
IT!
>> TIES IT WITH THREE!
SUGGS FOR THE WIN.
OH, YEAH!
>> THERE ARE ONIONS, JIM, AND
THERE ARE MAJOR ONIONS WITH A
KISS!
>> LET'S TAKE A LITTLE HISTORY
TONIGHT IN INDIANAPOLIS.
>> BUTLER.
>> RIGHT IN THE HEART.
>> COACH DREW AND BAYLOR,
COMPLETE COLLEGE BASKETBALL'S
GREATEST REBOUNDS AND REBUILD
WI